GARBAGE SALARIES:
$8,888,684. That’s how much
the United States’ highest paid government
employee earns. Can you guess who this
might be? Most people’s first guess is usually
government leaders. Maybe the president? Well,
the US president actually only earns $400,000
per year. Maybe supreme court justices? Well,
these guys only earn just over $200,000
on average. Ok, what about Jerome Powell,
he literally prints the money, so he should earn
a lot right? Well, even Jerome Powell only earns
just over $200,000 per year. Now, don’t get me
wrong here, these aren’t terrible salaries by
any means, but when you consider how much work
it takes to get these positions, it doesn’t
seem all that lucrative. If you’re a supreme
court justice for example, you’re literally 1
in 9, and you don’t even earn as much as a junior
software engineer at Facebook. But, wait a minute,
who’s the government employee who’s earning
$8.8 million then? Well, it’s not leaders,
or chairmen, or even politicians. It’s actually
the football coach at the University of Alabama:
Nick Saben. In fact, it’s not just Nick who tops
the government salaries list either. The top 10
government salaries all go to football coaches
at various public universities. While this may be
surprising at first glance, when you consider how
much revenue a good football coach can bring in,
their compensations start to make sense. But, this
doesn’t explain why regular government salaries
are so garbage. For example, Jerome Powell is
literally responsible for printing trillions
of dollars and inciting macro economic changes.
So, you would think that this job would be highly
compensated to attract the absolute best talent,
yet it’s not. But, you don’t even have to look
that high up the ladder to realize how underpaid
government employees are. Police officers,
for example, risk their lives to keep all of
us safe, yet they’re paid $70,000. Similarly,
teachers are responsible for educating
the next generation, yet they’re paid
$55,000. By far the worst one, however, is EMTs
who are directly responsible for saving millions
of lives, yet they’re only paid $36,000.
So, how did government salaries get so bad?
FUNDING:
One of the first explanations that pop up is
that government organizations are underfunded,
and this is why government employees are
underpaid. But, you don’t have to do much
analysis to recognize that this is completely
false. Federal government spending currently
clocks in at just under $6 trillion, and the US
currently has a total of 1.87 million federal
employees. This means that the revenue per
employee clocks in at a whopping $3.2 million
per employee. For perspective, Apple stands at
$1.9 million, Facebook stands at $1.6 million,
and Alphabet stands at $1.3 million. And these
companies are known as the highest paying
employers in the entire world. Apple’s numbers are
skewed due to their retail employees, but Facebook
and Google come in with median salaries of just
under $300,000. Conversely, the federal government
pulls in twice as much revenue per employee as
these companies, yet the average salary is only
$79,000. People often criticize private companies
for not paying their employees enough money,
but the average business actually pay out between
15 and 30% of their revenue as salaries. The
federal government, on the other hand, pays out
less than 2.5% of their revenue as salaries. Yeah,
it’s that bad. If the government matched
the average business and paid out 15 to 30%,
we would see average salaries between $480,000 and
$960,000. Even if they only paid out 10%, we would
see an average salary of $320,000, easily blowing
out the private industry. But, if that’s the case,
where’s all the money going? Well, the answer
is that it’s getting stuck up across inefficient
government structures. In many aspects, the
government operates as more of a charity than
a logical business. Take NASA for example. You
may have heard about their new SLS rocket. While
it’s definitely an impressive rocket, it's grossly
expensive coming in at $4.1 billion per launch and
it’s not even reusable. One of the main reasons
for this is that NASA is leveraging Space Shuttle
technology from the 1970s instead of the latest
and greatest. Why you ask? Well, it’s to protect
all of the industries and jobs that were dependent
on the Space Shuttle program. While this is a nice
sentiment, it’s not really all that practical, and
this is why private companies have been putting
NASA to shame. The SpaceX Falcon 9, for example,
only costs $67 million per launch while the Falcon
Heavy only costs $97 million per launch. Also,
that’s how much SpaceX is charging customers,
so their internal costs are likely even lower.
And in terms of payload, the Falcon Heavy has a
LEO payload capacity of 64 metric tons while SLS
has a LEO payload capacity of 70 metric tons. So,
SLS basically has 10% extra payload capacity
for 42 times the cost. As you can see,
the government doesn’t have a funding issue,
what they have is an ineffective spending issue.
COMPLACENT EMPLOYEES:
We can’t just lay all of the blame on the
government though as much of the low salaries
are due to the employees themselves and what
they’re willing to put up with. It’s no secret
that government jobs are relatively chill, and
while you can argue all you want about how great
a given company’s culture is, it’s simply not
comparable to the government. While the government
does have it’s own fair share of stressful
jobs, the vast majority are not. For example,
think about being a tax examiner at the IRS or
a clerk at the DMV. This laid back nature is
one of the biggest selling factors of the public
industry. Not to mention, the job security. But,
this also means that everyone who ends
up joining the public industry isn’t all
that particular about the pay. They of
course want to be paid a livable wage,
but they rarely look for more. This means that
they rarely ask for wage increases or promotions,
and they’re definitely not job hopping to maximize
pay. This is in stark contrast to the private
industry which has very much trended in this
direction. Employee loyalty is at all time lows,
and the days of people spending 40 or 50 years at
the same company are long gone. The same, however,
cannot be said about the government. It’s not
uncommon to see government employees who have
spent decades if not their entire careers at the
government. But, while the government has employee
loyalty, this simply leads to less competitive
salaries. When your employees are willing to stick
around regardless of whether you keep up with
market wages or inflation, it’s unlikely that you
actually keep up with market wages or inflation.
And given that most employees are complacent,
no one really does anything about. Now of course,
there are some unions who fight for better pay,
and they definitely put forth a valiant effort.
But, at the end of the day, they're really just
fighting for peanuts. For example, this one union
is trying increase the 2023 pay raise from 4.6% to
5.1%. I mean, they’re literally having to fight
over half a percent. In the private industry,
the tone is more like: if you’re not willing to
give me a $20,000 promotion, I’m gonna to switch
to someone who is. Something else to note is that
a large number of government employees aren’t even
there for the pay in the first place. Virtually
all government leaders are there for popularity,
power, and prestige, not for a paycheck. A similar
argument could be made for everyday employees as
well. Many of them are simply there for the
health insurance and the retirement benefits.
These people usually have spouses who work in the
private industry or they themselves worked in the
private industry and saved up a bunch of money
before switching over. So, they don’t actually
have to worry all that much about saving for
retirement or maximizing their pay. All they have
to do is pay their dues and cash out the benefits,
and that’s exactly what they’re looking to do.
NO CHOICE:
While
much of the public sector can be explained by
complacency, this isn’t true for everyone working
at the government. Unfortunately, a non negligible
portion of the public sector is filled with people
who don’t exactly what to be there, but they have
no other choice. This primarily consists of people
that the private sector views as undesirable or
unhirable. This doesn’t necessarily mean that
these employees are bad employees per se, but they
have traits that private companies just don’t want
to deal with. For example, a given employee
may have a long job gap on their resume. Now,
this employee may have a perfectly legitimate
reason for this gap. Maybe they were taking
care of a sick relative or maybe they were sick
themselves, but private companies don’t really
care about the reason. From their perspective,
this may be an indication that no one wants to
hire this person. Also, it’s more than likely that
the person is rusty at the job. So, the company
would rather just move onto the next applicant
than investigate further. Another popular hurdle
for many applicants is a lack of networking.
You would think that truly qualified candidates
would have no trouble finding a job, but this is
not actually the case especially during market
downturns. In fact, it’s way more valuable to have
an extensive professional network than just simply
have the skills given that the largest portion
of hires come from employee referrals. From the
company’s perspective, it makes way more sense
to bet on someone that a good employee is willing
to vouch for as opposed to someone that you have
to judge based on a piece of paper. And finally,
the last major group of people who have a
difficult time finding private jobs is people
with disabilities. While companies may be willing
to accommodate for someone with a wheel chair or
autism, it’s unlikely that they’ll deal with
someone whos deaf or blind. Now, technically,
it is illegal for employers to discriminate based
on an applicant’s disabilities, but if we’re being
real here, that’s not exactly how things play out.
Also, employers are allowed to discriminate if
they can argue that a given disability will limit
an individual from completing a job’s functions.
And this is not that hard of an argument to make
when the applicant is deaf or blind regardless of
the job. The government on the other hand, is
magnitudes more likely to give such candidate
a chance, and oftentimes, they’re the only
ones that give such candidates a chance. So,
while these people may not want to settle
for lower compensation at the government,
they really have no choice, and they
don’t have much negotiating power either.
THE STATE OF GOVERNMENT JOBS:
Low government salaries are nothing
new. The government has always paid less than the
private industry, but they usually made up for
this with better work life balance and benefits.
Over the past few decades though, the disparity
between private and government jobs has simply
grown larger and larger. And given the record
high inflation right now, the appeal of government
jobs is not nearly as clear. You can argue that
the government offers greater job security during
the recession, but at what cost? We’re not talking
about a salary difference of $50,000 at the
government vs $70,000 in the private industry.
We’re talking more like $50k at the government vs
$100k plus in the private industry. And that’s not
even account for promotions. At the government,
each promotions gets you an extra few thousand
dollars while a promotion in the private industry
usually gets you tens of thousands of dollars.
When you compound this reality over an entire
career, we’re talking about lower compensation
on the scale of millions of dollars. So, if
you’re currently working a government job or are
considering one, it may be time to reconsider your
options, but that’s just what I think. Would you
take a government job? Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think that government
employees are underpaid. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.